hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
whole bunch of news about the solo
Batman film that Ben Affleck is making
with Jeff Jones so this is gonna be a
breakdown of that so everybody saw Ben
Affleck at Comic Con he was there just
because they were bringing all the
directors for all the Justice League
related films like Zack Snyder is
directing justice league so he was there
Ben Affleck was there because he's
directing the Batman solo film but they
also had the director of the flash movie
they had the director of Suicide Squad
etc Affleck was recording it on his
phone it was really funny he's like this
is super nerdy but I just like a huge
deal for me so I'm just so happy to be
here so the big talk right now about the
Batman solo film is that you know Ben
Affleck has come out and said openly
that he's not going to make it till he's
ready to make it they're still writing
the script he's writing the script with
Geoff Johns if there was any mistake
about that
he and Geoff Johns are the only two
people they're gonna be working on that
script so I think even though
Christopher Nolan is still one of the
best authors working today like most of
his Batman films will still be like on
the top-five list of best Batman films
of all time you know no matter how many
more Batman films they make but I think
just with the talent behind this Batman
solo film they have a real solid chance
to make one of the top three Batman
films of all time
now usually where films like that fall
down is when you get too many cooks in
the kitchen but if you remember there's
been a lot of behind the scenes
reorganization with the way DC produces
its films so now tangential big news if
you guys didn't know about it Geoff
Johns is president of DC entertainment
in addition to chief creative officer
and films art like he's head of DC films
along with another producer and then
sort of within that he has complete
creative control this will actually make
you poop your pants a little bit
complete creative control of the new
Batman solo film so when they are
finally ready to actually like sit down
and film it it will probably be one of
the best Batman stories of all time now
that's a whole lot of news so I'll
circle back around to that Geoff Johns
stuff at the end of this video but the
real big question is is what is the
story going to be for this new Batman
film and pretty much everyone believes
now that it's going to be an Arkham
Asylum story done in the tone of the
raid if you don't know what the raid is
is this really amazing Korean film this
is basically a non-stop adrenaline rush
from the perspective of these police
that are fighting their way from the
bottom of this prison to the top to take
down a crime boss that
has taken over the prison so we don't
know which characters would be in it but
they say it would just be jam-packed
with Batman villains because Arkham
Asylum would naturally be filled with a
lot of Batman's worst enemies so if you
didn't know Arkham Asylum is set near a
cliff face so it actually goes down so
like ground level is almost like the
highest level so say the Joker takes
over Arkham Asylum releases all the
prisoners and has something that Batman
needs like Batman needs to take down the
Joker but he's at the bottom level so
for two hours Batman just fights his
what kicks his ass all the way down
level by level down til he gets to the
Joker so even though that's an
oversimplification does that not sound
like the most badass Batman action flick
ever like there's some Batman films that
are more existential there's some that
are more action based like The Dark
Knight is probably Christopher Nolan's
best Batman film it's kind of a blend of
the two
just remember the action sequence where
Batman saves Superman's mother in Batman
V Superman like it's just a non-stop
action right as he's just kicking ass
all over that warehouse til he saves her
imagine a two-hour version of that in
the people that he's being the out
of the criminals are just really big
Batman villains so you have all this
implied backstory because there's a
story for how Batman put those criminals
at like each one of those criminals in
Arkham is a different Batman story that
happens sometime in the past because
this is an older version of Batman who
had actually hung up the cape and cowl
before Batman V Superman so now that
he's put it back on they can have a lot
of fun with the way they addressed all
these past adventures that he's had now
the next big question you're asking is
is where would it appear in the timeline
because they've already got all these
other Justice League films that they're
making like they're the flash movie they
have the cyborg movie they have the
Aquaman movie there's Suicide Squad then
there'll be more sequels like there's
the Wonder Woman movie so what they'll
probably do just for the sake of
simplicity is they'll set it somewhere
in present-day in the timeline when you
do a film that says self-contained is
Batman fighting his way down to like the
Joker or another big villain at the
bottom of Arkham you don't really need
to acknowledge the timeline too much
like you can wink at things that have
happened in other movies but like
Superman doesn't need to appear in it so
you don't need to address whether or not
he's alive or dead maybe Batman gets
help from the flash or one of the other
Justice League members then you would
acknowledge some stuff that's been going
on but
was the only other things that you would
really want to acknowledge or have some
fun with is when Batman put each of
these criminals in Arkham like what was
that story how long ago did it happen
how long have they been in Arkham like
if we see two-face in Arkham Asylum or
if we see mr. freeze how long have they
been in there what was the story of how
Batman put them in there so of all the
different types of Batman movies that
they could make making an Arkham Asylum
movie is probably just the easiest slam
dunk that they could possibly be
delivered the way Ben Affleck has talked
about it so far is is that it won't be a
direct adaptation of any one particular
comic but it'll take inspiration from
several comics it might even take
inspiration from some of the Arkham
video games but if you're looking for
Arkham stories to read that are really
good they're they're actually several
Arkham is appeared in like three maybe
almost 400 different Batman comics so
yeah there are a lot of Arkham stories
to draw from but Arkham living hell is a
really crazy fever dream is just a
complete nightmare but an amazing story
Arkham Asylum a serious place on a
serious earth is also one of the best
Arkham stories of all time I mentioned
the Joker taking over Arkham he actually
did it during this story Grant Morrison
wrote it so you know it's a complete
acid trip it's totally amazing visually
stunning so The Joker takes over Arkham
Asylum takes the staff hostage Batman
has to go in and save everyone and take
the Joker down kick his ass so you can't
go wrong with Grant Morrison you can't
go wrong with the Joker taking over
Arkham and Batman beating the out
of them but let me know like what is
your favorite Batman Arkham story and do
you want Ben Affleck's Batman movie to
be in Arkham movie I just feel like it's
an easy slam-dunk and they're always
looking for movies that they can turn
into toys or rides you could totally
turn an Archimedean to a video game it
would be nonstop action it would be
amazing so just to circle back around to
Geoff Johns this was actually a bit of a
surprise for me the other day so I read
about the deal about him being promoted
to president of DC in addition to all
the other things that he's doing so it's
amazing news but the real surprises is
that they said that they did it like
they promoted him back in May right
after people started to freak out about
Batman V Superman so I think the reason
why they were bearing the lead like they
didn't say anything about it at Comic
Con Geoff Johns wasn't at Comic Con
which is a big deal usually he goes to
all the big conventions I think it's
just because they didn't want to steal
thunder from the
other DC films that they were trying to
promote like they didn't want to steal
thunder from Suicide Squad which is
coming out really soon they didn't want
to steal focus from Wonder Woman which
is coming out next year so it's very
understandable but everybody just give
Jeff John's a giant hi fire from the
screen most deserved promotion in all of
comics right now he really is like the
Kevin Feige of DC entertainment right
now so I'm so happy for him but in
celebration there's a new round of the
DC giveaway this week all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's a $20 Amazon
gift card there's a couple more DC
videos that I'll do this week my next
video is probably gonna be the flash
season 3 there's also some really cool
stuff going on with Supergirl season 2 I
know I haven't done a video from Comic
Con for that so after I do the flash
I'll do something for Supergirl season 2
so a lot more DC a lot more Marvel stuff
coming this week while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my
breakdown to the Wonder Woman trailer
and you can click here for my breakdown
of the flash season 3 trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight